>>
APPER.Y 6th SELECT H
"MGHT INHMO NOWMMITTEE MEMBERAN
W WET LOST
OUR DEMOCRACD STILL "
NGREMA
JOINING ORHOULD SAY.
YOU'RELS OF TH
HOUSE INTELLIGENEEFOR   AIED M
ITLA WEERDRAID OMAR-A-LAGO
N A-GO HEARD BACK FROM TLL? YOUO
THFOIS
PRECEDENT, A SEARCH OFEN
>> WE HAVEN'T RECE AE ME
HAT'G UNDERTAKEN
A-LAGO.O EXPECTATIONT LLITUSI LI
ER BES
AV
MARKINGS, IT GERES
IT COULD JEOPAE TH SULLYHEUMNY
INIGHT GAI
SOUINESS AND WE
EFFORT SHORT O THEOT IT.ERMSRLA
WARRANT TOE
MEIFPORTING IS AT TRUMP LAW
ASSERTED IN AN AID THAT
THEY HAD G ALLHE AND THE JUSTIC
DEPARTMENT HAD GOOLITH
S MEAN
GETTINTH THEUTION  SEARCH YEA VN
THAT IT WAUS AIATELY E CIRCUMCE
WILL CONSIDERA REDACTED VERSIO.
THE STNT IS,F
CO TEPT
ION, AT LEAST SOMEUMENT?DO YOUGH
ITR THIS YOU COULD L
FRHEIDAVIT.COULD LEARN WHATES EH
PEOPLE COMIND FROM
E THS WERE
LOCATED.
YOU COULD LEARN ABOUR
REPRESENTATIONS WERE MADE THAT
PROVE  BIN O
UE  INFORMATION.
YOCOA GREAT DEAL.
PROBLEM, THOE JUSTICE DEPARTMEN.
I THINK PROBABLY THEIR CONCERNY
THAT IF IF AFFIDAVIT IED
T LL SOURCK.
WE'VE SEEN THE PATE AGAINST ANY
A WHISTLOW,
ACCUSE THEM
OFRSN THE T'S C
LEAD SOMEONEO AN FBI
ASSAULT WEAPON,
DEDE THE FBI
SOTHNTIFY
I THTH TIM TC AFFIDA
AND I THINK THE STICE NT MAKES
JEOPARDIZEHEHI THE GIVING ESSEN
INTINTIMIDATE WITNE O A
LE INVESTIGATIONY YOU UNTA THE O
CONGRESSMAN EROH
SEARCH THIS TE
BEHAVIORS TEY ALSO
UNPRECEDENTED, BUT A SEARCD  CO
>>BSOLUTELY.TION I AAL INVESTI
A DR TO THE NATIONAL
SECURITY INFORMATION  THOSE DOCS
HAD WITH CONGRESS, T IS NOT.
BUSEE CONGRESS
OR ANYON INTERFERE WITH
INVESTIGATION.
I'D LIKE TO MAKE SURE WE DO OUOP
PENCFEW  MHTE AVAILABL TESTIFY
FO JANUARY 6thTATION WAS ND I E
YOUR REACTION?TO HEAR IT HOPE I
SOUNDED LIKE IT MEANT.
WE HAVE BEEN ISCREDE FORHE KNOW
WAY TOORK EGE OR SEPARATN  SSUE.
OF COURSE, NHE
E DECI TO COME BEFORE
HE COULD PLAINLY SHARE AF THE IU
ION OF WHAT IT
WAS LIKE T SOSE EFFORTS TO GET L
POWER T
T ANRICAN
IDENTIAL E
DGHR OF
THE INVASIONLLED CARIASPONSIIS
ANYTHINGHI
WHO DO YOU THINK I IT?
>> WE HAVEOT YET BEEN BRIEFEON S
INTERNINN THE
PE INTERNAVENT.ANYTHING IS I CEH
RUSSIAND WN'
SOG EMANATING FROM
UKRAINE.
WE HE R CRIMES
AND RUSSIABE HNST
ACWOULD CERTAINLY NEVER WANT TOC
CIVILIANS BY UKRNE HOPE
EI
CORRECT.
>> TIDNS
JU9 DAYSKER PE
RO
FTTERMERHIND THE SCENES TO PLOR
WOULD YOU WANT TO BEDE
ICS?>>K THR HAEN TRULYOST
IMIMND
PRODUCTIVE SPE I
HISTORY.
SO, HO. DT TO
ALL I'D KIE
SUCC WHA A MITE NEXTKLEN
THMEUMO R DIRECTION AND WE
HAVE A GREATERREATER
OF HOLDING